Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich habe gehört, die Bundesregierung will sich jetzt fünf, statt drei Tagen empören in einem typischen NSA-Zyklus.
Wenn das mal reicht.
Laut Buchnetzpolitik einhundertundacht. Hm, so sieht's nämlich aus hier. Wir können nämlich zählen.
Ja, hier, hi.
Ihr könnt auf uns zählen und wir vollbringen hier äh aritmethische Nachweise unserer Basisintelligenz.
Da ist man ja jetzt bei der Bundesregierung noch nicht ganz so sicher, ob das äh so gelingt. Mit dem Nachweis der Basisintelligenz,
Pass nicht, also zählen. Unzählige Male. Vollführen sie immer wieder denselben Tanz und.
Ein Mitarbeiter des BND zwei namentlich bekannte Spionageopfer und bei drei.
Da
Reicht's aber dann jetzt auch wirklich.
Wird mal so richtig auf den Tisch gehauen. Wollen wir das nochmal kurz machen?
Ja. Hier ich habe, warte mal, ich, also wir müssen ich habe dir, ich habe ja hier schon gezeigt gestern, wie Merkel auf den Tisch haut.
Das Zitter äh das Zittergift.
Das Zittergift, das finde ich sehr schön, das ist ja dann mal gleich in den,
in den Dingens hier, ne.
Ja, also man dreht total durch. Das ist äh gut. Wir allerdings, wir ähm wir drehen nicht total durch, weil wir sind ja jetzt schon so dermaßen gehärtet und gestellt äh uns kann ja gar nichts mehr, ne? Oder?
Weiß ich nicht, was noch kommt.
Ja, ist äh schwierig, ne. Ja, man weiß nicht, was kommt, aber äh wir können ja auch der Sache mal chronologisch folgen. Das wäre ja doch sozusagen.
Ey, soll ich ausgerechnet diese Woche, dass man nicht wirklich chronologisch gemacht? Ich habe die nämlich die.
Ja, Entschuldigung, ich wollte auch was anderes sagen. Ich wollte eigentlich nur äh aufsteigend durch unsere Programmpunkte äh durchmarschieren.
Okay, machen wir, ne?
Ja, dann müssen wir mal mit irgendwas anfangen. Womit fangen wir an?
Wir fangen an mit dem BND Mitarbeiter.
Ja, da gibt's auch Mitarbeiter, wie wir erfahren haben,
Es gibt äh tatsächlich äh wie soll ich sagen, Versuchungen, denen sie erliegen, erliegen, äh wenn mal die anderen Dienste anfragen, die vielleicht ein bisschen besser bezahlen als die Poststelle.
Ja das also es handelt sich um einen Sachbearbeiter im BND Archiv,
dessen Aufgabe hauptsächlich in dem entgegennehmen und einscannen von Dokumenten bestand, also völlig unkritische Aufgabe.
Mhm. Also ein Disketten-Insatier. Ja.
So in der Art. Ähm und da hat er über zwei Jahre lang insgesamt zweihundertachtzehn Dokumente äh an,
Amerikaner übergeben in diesem Fall an die CIA, die sich wohl dann irgendwie äh,
der NSA dann auch mal langsam Paroli bieten wollte im in um die Kunst. Ähm und dafür fünfundzwanzigtausend Euro bekommen hat,
und aufgefallen ist, weil er jetzt den Fehler begangen hat, eine Mail an das Generalkonsulat Russland zu senden und ähm,
Er hat vorher nicht mal,
geschaut wurde, der Mailserver vom Generalkonsulat Russlands steht. Der löst nämlich auf äh T Online auf,
Ja, das ist kein Scheiß. Und dann hat er meinst, ich denk mir sowas aus.
Das geht.
Und dann hat er äh.
Also das Generalkonsulat in Deutschland.
Ich muss nochmal kurz gucken.
Generalkonsulat, also nicht die Botschaft.
Also russische Botschaft, ja, also wenn du wenn du äh russische Botschaft DE machst, dann sagt er dir, dass äh der Mailserver dafür SMTP null eins Punkt TLD Punkt T Online DE.
Also general, also um da mal zu unterscheiden, also es gibt ja die Botschaft, dass es quasi so da, wo der Botschafter sitzt, der auch mit der Regierung konferiert und dann gibt's die Konsulate, die quasi hoheitliche
Dienste für russische Bürger und Leute, die dort hinfahren wollen, übernehmen. Die gibt's dann auch in anderen Städten. Und es gibt zum Beispiel einen Generalkonsulat in,
Bonn, die dürfen dann halt alles machen, außer jetzt, sagen wir mal den Staat als solchen politisch zu vertreten.
So, dann gucken wir mal ganz kurz.
Wahrscheinlich auch nicht ganz so viele Geheimdienste. Das ist hier.
Konsulat Bonn ist bei MX null null Punkt Kundenserver DE,
Kundenserver DE hört sich jetzt auch nicht nach einem rus,
äh Kunstsever DE habt, macht auf Port achtzig erstmal eine vier null vier. Ähm cooles.
Es ist eins und eins, also es wäre jetzt auch nicht entweder bei Eins und Eins bei der bei der Telekom gelandet. Ähm elegant war als Absenderadresse hat er dann eine Gmail Adresse genommen.
Aha.
Und das war gar nicht so blöd von ihm, denn,
Mit den Amis hat er bisher gute Erfahrungen gemacht, denn die Amerikaner sind nicht Ziel der deutschen Spionageabwehr. Ja, das heißt, er konnte halt die ganze Zeit schön mit den Amis.
Mhm.
Weil deren Mailserver nicht bei ähm,
nicht bei äh bei T Online liegen. Und außerdem kontrollieren, das heißt, der ist quasi immer so in deren Heimatgebiet gegangen, um dann da seine seinen Kran zu machen. Ja, er hat sich überlegt.
Was hat er denn denn geschrieben?
Ja, er hatte geschrieben, hallo, wollt ihr hier Dokumente haben, liebe Russen?
Ja sicher, moderner, junger Mann, kann eine E-Mail schreiben. So und dann äh Enno halt nicht von G-Mail zu T Online. So und dann haben die ähm.
Ich bitte dich, Spionageanbahnung über E-Mail.
Man, der ist vom BND, weil jetzt kannst du das nicht irgendwie.
Woher soll der das denn wissen?
Er ist das Ketten in Satira professioneller.
Die wussten doch von nichts. Beim BND,
Also so und dann haben.
Oh Gott, Leute.
Ja, pass auf, pass auf, lass mal zu Ende jetzt hin. Also die die deutsche Spionageabwehr hat das gemerkt, weil sie dich offensichtlich, die bei T Online oder Eins und Eins gehostete Mails der Russen lesen,
Und haben gesehen, oh, was ist das denn hier? Einer vom BND will da äh will liegen. Ja?
Und dann haben sie bei den Amerikanern angerufen, haben gesagt, ey könnt ihr uns mal sagen, wem diese Gmail Adresse gehört,
und dann haben die Amerikaner gesagt und dann wurde die Adresse auf einmal gelöscht und existierte nicht mehr. Mit anderen Worten, wahrscheinlich haben die,
für die Amerikaner so aus, dass der BRD fragt äh oder das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz müsste eigentlich Spionageabwehr machen
fragt, ey, Amis, sagt mal kurz hier Amtshilfe, wer ist das? Und dann haben die Amis gesagt, oh der.
Wissen wir jetzt nicht. Wir wissen ja auch nicht alles. Ist ja nicht so, dass wir jetzt ja alles überwachen würden.
So und dann haben die Amis den wohl gesagt, dann äh wurde halt diese ähm dieses G-May-Konto gelöscht und ähm.
Wobei die sich natürlich auch gefreut haben dürften zu hören, dass sozusagen ihr kleiner Spionagevogel einfach auch an Maisbietenden verkauft.
Davon muss ja bei Spionagevögeln ohnehin ausgehen, ne.
Ja, das ist ja total Schocking. Ich dachte, die machen das alles wegen einer inneren politischen Überzeugung, um äh dem dem Warensystem zum Erfolg des wahren Systems zum Erfolg zu führen.
Ja, das ist aber echt irgendwie fünfziger Jahre, ne?
Ja, habe ich so im im Kino gesehen. Das äh.
Ja. Auf jeden Fall äh,
Im Moment ist der Nachrichtenstand, dass die CIA plant eventuell zuzugeben, dass das der Fall war, dass sie mit diesem Manda kooperiert haben und dass ähm,
Das Schöne ist, dass das jetzt schon wieder so eine ähm,
Also ich meine, weißt du, wenn du einen Geheimdienst bist und es kommt jemand von einem anderen Geheimdienst und sagt, ich schicke dir was rüber? Dann sagst du natürlich klar, mach mal!
Ich meine, einfacher kann deine Arbeit ja nicht gemacht werden. Das ist völlig normal, dass du es als Geheimdienst natürlich machst. Ähm,
Aber das ist jetzt wieder sowas, was halt wo es halt voll abgeht, ne?
Gauck hat sich ja dann da irgendwie im ZDF-Interview am Sonntag äh zur besten Sendezeit hingestellt, hat gesagt,
Also wenn sich jetzt herausstellen sollte, dass da tatsächlich was dran wäre, dann müsste man ja echt tatsächlich fast mal sagen, dass äh es jetzt aber vielleicht auch genug sein könnte. So,
theoretisch, ne? Also wenn sich das jetzt alles wahr halten sollte.
Ja, er sollte, wenn, also.
Und ähm ja, wenn ich, wie gesagt, bin ich halt auch.
Das muss man, glaube ich, ganz dringend mal untersuchen. Da muss man ja jetzt wirklich Nachforschung äh da muss der Generalbundesanwalt mal eingeschaltet werden, der kann dann ein Jahr lang prüfen, ob es unter Umständen einen Anfangsverdacht gibt.
Genau. Das Spannende ist das Spannende ist ja, dass äh es dann auch noch um den NSA Untersuchungsausschuss ging. Das heißt, die äh der Typ hat den,
den NSA Untersuchungsausschuss angeblich so lautet, da war ja so die Gerüchtelage, was genau er da geliebt hat, ist ja noch nicht bekannt,
dass er quasi für die für die CIA den NSA Untersuchungsausschuss in Deutschland überwacht,
oder ausspioniert haben soll. Und jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wenn er im BND-Archiv ist, wo man davon ausgeht, dass dieses BND-Archiv seine Primärquelle ist.
Auf jeden Fall im NSA Untersuchungsausschuss schon mal ganz gut zugegen.
Dann fragt man sich, wie denn der BND? Offensichtlich da überwacht haben sie, aber okay, nichts Genaues weiß man nicht.
Ja aber es ist auch geil. So was wird dann auch wieder überhaupt nicht thematisiert? So, der eigentliche Skandal ist, oh mein Gott, äh der die NSA kopiert uns jetzt die gestohlenen Dokumente des unseres Geheimdienstes, der uns hier gerade spioniert, ob
wohl ja die Kontrolle eigentlich anders rumlaufen sollte und irgendwas ist doch hier falsch.
Es ist super und jetzt jetzt versuchen wir natürlich äh also es ist natürlich jetzt interessanter,
interessantes Problem für die äh für die deutschen Geheimdienste, die jetzt irgendwie sagen müssen, ja, hm, der hat zwei Jahre lang offensichtlich Regel für die Amerikaner spioniert,
zweihundertachtzehn Dokumente, ne.
Fünfzehn Euro pro.
Das sind irgendwie zwei pro Woche in zwei Jahren, ne?
Ist er jetzt auch nicht nicht besonders viel Geld, ehrlich gesagt.
Ein bisschen knapp, ja? Also hätte ich hätte gedacht, die Zahlen besser, aber ähm offensichtlich war der, also,
Wie gesagt, nichts Genaues weiß man nicht. Ähm der BND ist jetzt sehr damit bemüht, ihn irgendwie als,
Seine Bedeutung herunterzuspielen als äh eine Hilfskraft, die da eben im Archiv gearbeitet hat ähm.
Pro Monat dazu verdient hat.
Genau. Die Hilfskraft äh ist übrigens eine von zweihundert Mitarbeitern in der Abteilung und das fand ich sehr schön, weil ähm,
Presseanfragen kamen so zu der äh zu der Info des BND,
ein großer deutscher Fernsehsender fragte dann, ob der CCC nicht mal was dazu sagen wollen würde.
Machen können.
Nee, nee. Wie so ungefähr, also Tenor der Anfrage war, wie kann das denn sein?
Einfach so Daten äh raustragen kann. Ob da nicht der CCC mal irgendwie äh die Infos der Guidelines äh zitieren möchte. Und dann habe ich nur so zurückgeschrieben, so ähm,
Edward Snowden ist mit einem USB-Stick rausmarschiert. Chelsea Manning mit einer mit einer gebrannten CD,
Ähm und sollen wir uns jetzt irgendwie darüber aufregen, dass das beim BND auch möglich ist? Also man muss dazu sagen, es gibt natürlich so Systeme, das ist äh in den letzten Jahren in der Enterprise Security irgendwie sowas, was was gerne verkauft wird. Äh DLP
Äh Data Los oder Data Leakage äh Prevention Systeme, wo dann irgendwie
quasi die die ganzen Firmenrechner Teil eines äh zentralen Botnetz der Firma sind, das äh verbietet zum Beispiel bestimmte Geräte an USB anzuschließen.
Unter anderem eben USB-Sticks. Ähm und äh die die Mitarbeiter dazu zwingt, quasi zentral irgendwie auf einem.
Ob da jetzt kein Produktnamen zu nennen, äh die Dateien auszutauschen, sodass die dass dass das nicht mehr passiert, dass die Leute mit USB-Sticks hantieren oder so. Ist natürlich totaler Quatsch, weil das Einzige, was das Ergebnis davon ist, ist, dass die dass die Mitarbeiter trainiert werden darin,
ähm,
wie ihre Daten halt zu dem möglichst unseriöses Cloud-Anbieter zu schieben und irgendwie über Rapid Share zu tauschen oder so, um irgendwie dieses DLP zu äh umgehen,
Ähm insofern das sind strukturelles Problem, überall da wo äh irgendwie elektronische Informationsverarbeitungen stattfindet.
Vielleicht auch noch was für Kim Schmitz. Mega. Mega mega security.
Mega sicher.
Mega, mega, mega Infos weg.
Mega sex,
ich gehe gleich mal ein paar Domains shoppen.
Schon weg.
Ja und jetzt haben wir halt dieses Problem und aber was was ich ja spannend finde ist, dass sich ähm die ganze Zeit wieder also jetzt regen sich dann hier die äh Merkel und der und der Gauck auf, ne?
Das Spannende ist, dass die sich die sind nach wie vor bei diesen alten,
Spionagemethoden, ne? Also, Telefone abhören, Doppelagenten anwerben, da sind die so riesen,
Da sind die so richtig aus, da da sind die da geben die dann Interviews, da klopfen die dann auf den Tisch und so, ne. Also Massenüberwachung der Bevölkerung, da sagen die so, ja komm, Internet und so, ne, also das ist ja auch alles, das wächst sicher,
Internet, ne? Ja auch überall nur Kruppzeug drin. Und äh ihr diese da das ist irgendwie ja, das ist ja nur virtuell,
So ist das nämlich.
Ah, ach so, das ist nur scheinbar.
Ich glaube, das ist so das.
Ist eigentlich gar nicht so.
Ja, dem guten Mann stehen jetzt fünf Jahre Haft in schweren Fällen zehn in Aussicht,
für geheimnisliche Agententätigkeit auf deutschem Boden. Jetzt frage ich mich natürlich,
Ich war eigentlich etwas überrascht, weil dieses Strafmaß mir relativ gering vorkommt. Also fünf Jahre Haft ist, glaube ich, dann die äh die Höchststrafe,
oder Innenstadt, ich weiß es nicht genau, weil fünf bis zu fünf in schweren Fällen zehn Jahre Haft äh stehen dem entgegen. Ich glaube, in anderen Ländern äh wird äh für sowas dann der Kopf abgemacht, oder?
Ja, also.
Amputat, fachgerecht.
Da gibt's auf jeden Fall äh ja, ich meine, sehen wir ja, was hier so potenziell, Menning
und so weiter äh droht in ähnlichen Fällen. Also das sind da dann auch gleich mehrere lebenslängliche Strafen, die da zusammensummiert werden. Also ich weiß nicht, was da mal checkt, waren wir irgendwie, glaube ich, über dreihundert Jahre
dir da äh oder dieser einsetzen soll,
Keine Ahnung für Herrn Assange haben sie sicherlich auch noch ein interessantes äh juristisches Paket äh zusammen, wenn's irgendwie äh mal angefragt wird. Ja, keine Ahnung. Also.
Ja, will ich mich jetzt also.
Ich meine, der ist jetzt sicherlich kein großer Fisch. So, weil ich meine fünfundzwanzigtausend Euro bitte dich, ja.
Ja, das klingt ein bisschen nach Wichtig.
Ja, aber dann irgendwie eine Mail. Also Leute, echt. Also dafür muss man auch fünf Jahre in Haft.
Ja die die man würde also man muss ja beides, bei der engen zusammen.
Internetkompetenz.
Nein, nein, bei der bei der engen Zusammenarbeit zwischen NSA, Ulm oder amerikanischen Geheimdiensten und BND. Hätte man erwarten können,
dass in einem solchen Falle, die Amerikaner sagen,
In eurem BND, in der und der Abteilung, da müsst ihr mal aufpassen. Und den müsst ihr als erstes feuern und bei den anderen hundertneunundneunzig müsst ihr auch mal äh.
Genau. Weil vielleicht geht der morgen ja zu den Russen. So wie der drauf ist.
So und ähm das haben die Amerikaner nicht getan, stattdessen haben sie gesagt, ja wunderbar, mach mal. Das werden sie jetzt erklären müssen.
Unter Freunden, das geht ja gar nicht.
Unter Freunden geht das gar nicht. Nö. Ja äh ich find's halt äh.
Also es wird auf jeden Fall ein schöner Eiertanz werden. Das äh lässt sich jetzt, glaube ich, schon mal ganz gut sagen.
Ja, also ich bin mal gespannt, wie sie sich aus der Nummer wieder rausreden. Es gab einen sehr schönen ähm sehr schönen,
sehr schöne Überraschung. Der Beitrag selber war eigentlich nicht besonders schön oder nicht besonders toll formuliert, aber Sabine Leuthäuser Schnarrenberger, unsere ehemalige Bundesjustizministerin, hat dann auf Heise DE ähm,
die Forderungen,
aufgestellt, man könne das doch jetzt mal zum Anlass nehmen, um äh diesen äh lächerlichen ähm Cyber-Dialog äh mal langsam abzubrechen.
Keinen Sinn hat.
Zum Beispiel, ne? Und,
wo ist denn der Link jetzt hin? Meine Güte, das heißt aber heute viel publiziert, dass der noch nicht mal mehr finde. Äh Cyber, Dezemberdialog, abbrechen. Da ist er.
Andererseits, wie gesagt, ich gehe eigentlich davon aus, dass das eine, dass das ein relativ normaler Vorgang ist, dass ein Geheimdienst äh sowas macht. Und ist aber vielleicht auch schön, weil vielleicht kann man das jetzt so spinnen, dass die ähm,
dass auch die die Bundesregierung oder die Politiker, unsere Herrenpolitiker, die da oben mal,
verstehen, warum nicht immer schlecht ist, wenn man Daten sammelt und spioniert.
Und warum das Missbrauchspäse äh Potenzial muss Missbrauchspersonal, dass äh Missbrauchspotential eben immer,
da und hoch ist. Ja? Also das äh wo ein Druck ist, da kommen die Schweine ähm,
eben egal für welchen Druck gilt.
Aber ich glaube, es ist äh schwierig ähm davon auszugehen. Es gibt auf jeden Fall äh so äh wurde auf der auf dem Fachblatt für ähm,
Politik Metronaut DE dann angekündigt eine Imagekampagne der Jungen Union zur Abschaffung der Geheimdienste.
Was?
Wir verlinken das mal.
Ich glaube, wir können zum nächsten äh Thema gehen.
Machen wir das doch.
Denn das andere große äh das andere große NSA äh und Überwachungslied dieser Woche war dann das äh,
das Veröffentlichen von Auszügen von etwas, was bezeichnet wurde als Ex-Kiescore Quelltext. Ähm und das waren,
so
C plus plus Oide Suchanf Suchdefinitionen, die offensichtlich irgendwie in diesem Exkiescore gepasst werden.
Ähm da komme ich gleich zu. Ähm,
Und da standen dann so schöne Anweisungen drin wie äh wenn äh Suchbegriff bei Google gleich Tales oder ähm,
Webseite gleich Punkt Boom Punkt org. Dann äh Nutzer will Tales suchen,
markieren.
Tales. Schwänze.
Tales ist ein nein, Tales ist ein Livesystem, VM-Nischek Inkognito Lifesystem,
Das ist ein äh also ein so ein Live USB System, wo alles irgendwie in Tor bootet
und also dann ein drauf ist, was äh OTR benutzt und alles aller Traffic irgendwie durch Tor geschoben wird, ja? Das ein System, was sich also empfiehlt, um,
wenn man seinem,
Rechner jetzt als als normalen Nutzer nur ein Minimalvertrauen entgegenbringt und auch seine eigenen Kompetenz diesen abzusichern, kein Vertrauen entgegenbringt, dann kann man dieses Tales einfach mal booten,
und hat damit ein relativ äh gut gehärtetes, anonymisiertes System, mit dem man dann eben,
Schabernack treiben kann.
Okay, so ein Secure-Liveboot-CD.
Genau, also ist eigentlich so das das Tor-Live-System so,
ja. Und äh das war also äh das führte irgendwie dazu, dass man da getargetet wird. Ähm auch ähm,
Wenn man irgendwie äh auf Lynux Journal dot com geht, dann wurde man halt irgendwie als Extremist ähm erkannt, also klar, ne, Extremist, also du kennst ja al-Qaida.
Terroristen.
Und äh Linox Forum. Hm, also das sind so die drei. Das sind so die drei großen Extremistengruppen, ne?
Jetzt wird mir einiges klar.
Und ähm gab's da noch weitere noch weitere Suchen drin und dann fanden sie,
bei der Untersuchung dieser Sachen, dass auch eine bestimmte IP-Adresse, eine Reihe von IP-Adressen spezifisch gefleckt war,
Und wir bleiben also bei dem Anonymisierungsdienst Thor, der äh wie wir ja alle,
hoffentlich wissen, grob so funktioniert, dass es ein Netzwerk gibt aus Rechnern, die alle miteinander verschlüsselt kommunizieren, wo jeder Traffic mindestens,
zwei Umwege nimmt,
nämlich, dass er erstmal ein eine andere an in das Tor Netzwerk reingeht, das ist dann die Entry Note, dann,
An eine Middle Note geht, die zwar die Entry Note kennt und die Exit-Note, aber nicht denjenigen, der an die Entry Note geschrieben hat,
Und von dieser Mittelnot dann eventuell auf mehreren Umwegen, aber letztendlich an eine Exit-Note kennen, geht die, wenn es dann wieder ins richtige Internet geht, zwar weiß, wo es hingeht, nicht jedoch mehr weiß, von wem der Traffic kam,
Ähm.
Und dabei wird das Ganze immer schön in Zwiebelscheiben.
Das Ganze wird immer schön rumrotiert, genau, kryptographisch wird's also ähm so verschlüsselt, dass die Entry Note sieht, ah,
es geht weiter über diese Mittelnot, die Mittel Nord sieht ASG zu dieser Endnot und die N-Note sieht, ah das ist der Traffic, den ich rausgeben muss. Aber das heißt, jeder einzelne Note ähm hat immer nur ein einzelnes Wissen und nicht,
Das Gesamtwissen über wer der die abfragende Person ist und wer die Zielseite ist,
Ähm das Ganze natürlich noch mit vielen äh weiteren Komplizierungen, aber grundsätzlich kann man das so vielleicht ähm,
vereinfacht erklären, äh sehr zu empfehlen, sich einfach mal das den Tor Browser runterzuladen und diesen zu nutzen,
ähm oder sich mal genauer einzulesen, wie das System funktioniert. Entscheidend ist es, scheint so eines der letzten Verfahren zu sein, die im Moment noch äh halbwegs sinnvolle Anonymisierungen der,
im Internet bieten.
Unter mehreren Einschränkungen, die man sich dann da selber auferlegen muss, damit man auch anonym bleibt. Also wenn ich mich damit dann bei Facebook einlogge, habe ich mir jetzt keinen großartigen Gefallen getan, weil Facebook ja dann eh weiß, wer ich bin.
So und jetzt muss am Anfang der Herr des Herstellens einer Torverbindung, muss ich ja quasi einmal wissen,
wo ich überhaupt hin,
schicken kann, um ins Tor reinzukommen um in diesen in diese Torwolke reinzukommen. Und dafür gibt es eine relativ geringe Anzahl sogenannter Directory Server,
beziehungsweise äh autoritativer Directory Server.
Also ein Verzeichnis der Rechner, die als Tor Entry Note fungieren, wo man halt überhaupt erstmal sein Traffic hinschicken kann, damit er danach innerhalb des Tor Netzwerks eben in auf die genannte Art und Weise verwurstet und woanders wieder ausgespuckt wird.
Genau. Und der Directory Server gibt dir quasi eine Liste von Eingängen, von denen du dir dann einen auswählen kannst. Und,
Wenn mein Ziel jetzt ist, zu identifizieren, wer Tor nutzt,
dann könnte ich entweder die ganze Zeit diese Directory Server fragen, welche IP-Adressen sind grade welche IP-Adressen sind grade
und gucken, wer verbindet sich zu diesem Tor und dann irgendwie riesig komplizierte, sich ständig ändernde Abfragen haben?
Oder ich könnte sagen, ach super. Jeder, der einmal zu einem dieser Directory-Server,
Der nutzt offensichtlich Tor, weil er fragt ja gerade, wie er da reinkommt. Und genau eine solche ähm,
oder eine solche Suchmaske gab's eben auch in diesem Exkiescore. Und einer dieser äh Directory Server,
der dann da gefunden wurde, äh wurde von einem deutschen äh Studenten betrieben.
Aber ist ja interessant, ja? Also man man versucht sozusagen gar nicht äh den eigentlichen Traffic äh zu,
analysieren oder beziehungsweise man hat es vielleicht versucht, aber ist jetzt nicht sonderlich äh erfolgreich damit.
Geht dann einfach den einfacheren Weg und sagt, naja,
um überhaupt erstmal damit anfangen zu können, braucht man Zugang dazu, da existiert natürlich zu dem Zeitpunkt noch keinerlei Verschleierung
potentiell alle Leute, die halt ähm auf der Party nach äh Haschisch fragen, werden wahrscheinlich später auch welches konsumieren und sind schon mal verdächtig.
Ja, ich würde mich jetzt dagegen wehren, äh dass mit Haschisch äh gleichzusetzen, aber klar ist es. Das ist der, der beste Angriff, den du dagegen tust, den du oder die beste Möglichkeit, die du hast, um das zu überwachen, ist eigentlich also sehr,
sehr logisch, dass auf diesem Wege zu tun, zu gucken, wer nutzt Thor,
jeder andere Möglichkeit, Tornutzung zu detektieren, ähm ist intensiver,
Also du könntest natürlich auch gucken, okay
äh spricht ja die ganze Zeit irgendwie verschlüsselt auf auf verrückten Ports durch die Gegend. Das ist natürlich auch ein Hinweis, aber dass das festzustellen ist eben sehr viel teurer als einmal nur kurz zu gucken, ah, hat er sich dahin verbunden? Alles klar, der nutzt jetzt Tor,
Das heißt, es ist einfach die äh,
vermutlich ressourcenschonendste Möglichkeit, Tornutzer schnell zu erkennen. Und das haben sie da getan. So und jetzt haben sie also diesen äh deutschen Studenten,
der dann bezeichnet wurde als.
Wer ist denn jetzt sie eigentlich in dem Zusammen.
Ja, wie ich ja gerade, lass mich doch mal meinen Satz hier,
So, also die die NDR-Leute ähm die diese Daten dann, glaube ich, als allererstes veröffentlicht haben, haben in diese Ex-Keescore geschaut,
haben gesehen, oh, da ist eine IP-Adresse, haben gesehen, oh, das ist eine deutsche IP-Adresse und haben festgestellt, wem diese IP-Adresse gehört.
Ja? Und wer diesen Server, der sich hinter dieser IP-Adresse verbirgt, betreibt. Und das ist ein deutscher Student und,
dann haben sie den besucht und haben gesagt, hier ah, guck mal hier, du bist dein Server wird hier überwacht. Was ist denn da los? Da hat der gesagt, ja, so. Einer, der einer der großen zentralen, wichtigen Directory Server für Thor,
Ja und äh dann wurde er, glaube ich, so zwei Tage lang irgendwie durch die Medien gebrannt, als der ähm,
als der äh zweite, das zweite namentlich bekannte NSA Überwachungsopfer.
Ja
Das ist ganz geil, ne? Also ähm.
Achtzig Millionen gemutmaßten.
Jetzt schon zwei.
Schon zwei sind schon bekannt geworden, also wenn es so weitergeht in dem Speed.
Also diesen Spin finde ich schon echt übel. Diesen Spin finde ich schon wirklich übel, das jetzt auf diese Person zu beziehen, denn das, was was wirklich,
Also das Ziel dieses,
Dieses Überwachungsdingens, ja? War spezifisch einfach nur Tornutzer und genau diese eine Person nicht, was,
eben schlimmer ist vielleicht, aber gleichzeitig auch verständlich, wie gesagt, aus technischer Sicht macht es Sinn, das genau äh so zu tun.
Ähm andererseits haben sie aber dann wohl auch weitere äh,
Weitere, weiteres Interesse an seiner Person gehabt, natürlich als ein ähm als ein Betreiber dieser zentralen Infrastruktur, haben sie ihn,
Unter Umständen, so wie es hier scheint, eben auch noch weiter äh zum zu ihrem Ziel gemacht,
Aber insgesamt war ich also mit dieser Beschreibung des Problems nur so mittel happy.
Ja, bestätigt natürlich ein altes äh Vorurteil so, wenn man Verschlüsselung äh benutzt, macht man sich verdächtig.
Das trifft hier an der Stelle äh leider voll zu, ne. Weil's halt nicht genug Leute machen.
Ja und das ist ein, das war interessant. Das war die die äh die der sinnvolle Spin, den man dazu äh geben musste, ist natürlich, dass man sagt, okay, hier sinnvoll wäre es jetzt,
Dass halt mehr Leute Tor nutzen, ist immer sinnvoll, ja? Aber das wäre jetzt nochmal ein ähm,
Ein Anlass, das zu verstärken. Ähm gleichzeitig hat dann der gute äh,
der also eines Sicherheitsforscher aus den USA dann noch ein bisschen interessante Sachen äh dazu geschrieben.
Wie man diesen Code, den er da so gesehen hat, der allerdings auch schon ein paar Jahre ähm,
älter ist. Ähm durch also irgendwie austricksen kann. Also wonach suchen die, ja?
Und was man also was man eventuell tun kann, um diesen Code irgendwie zu jämmen. Andererseits ist das äh,
Andererseits auch uninteressant, weil in dem Moment, wo er das veröffentlicht und Leute das befolgen und die NSA sieht, was die Leute, die ihre Datenbank da gerade durcheinander bringen wollen, tun. Können sie natürlich auch wieder dafür korrigieren, dass sie,
dass ihnen das eben nicht passiert, ja. Ähm der Rob ist Rob Graham ist ohnehin irgendwie so ein bisschen,
ähm ja, der ist nicht so ganz auf der auf der Seite der Freiheit in diesem Bereich. So, es ist ja schon so ein bisschen kritisch und so, aber äh,
nimmt dann auch in anderen Artikeln dann irgendwie Kieferexender, in Schutz und äh greift irgendwie Jacob Apple-Baum an und so. Das der ist da irgendwie offensichtlich, hat er da einige äh mit seiner Firma einige Contracts in, im,
äh die er gerne behalten möchte. Wäre jetzt so meine meine Unterstellung. Aber auch ein ganz interessanter, interessantes,
lesen dazu. Aber wie gesagt, diesen Spin
irgendwie aus einer Massenüberwachung auf oder einer Massendetektion von Nutzern, die offensichtlich auf ihre Privatsphäre achtgeben möchten und das behandeln selbiger als Extremisten
und das setzen auf eine äh zumindest enger, engmaschigere Überwachungsliste ähm halte ich dafür, dass.
Problem. Wer eine Directory Affarity von Tor betreibt, der weiß, dass er sich damit äh.
In dieses äh ins Visier bringt, ja, genau.
Beziehungsweise nicht also sich selbst ist nochmal eine Sache, aber ähm.
Auch andere.
Potentiell auch andere, das heißt, da betreibt man Infrastruktur, wo man schon genau wissen sollte, was man tut.
Ja, stellt sich natürlich die Frage.
Dieses Vertrauen betreiben zu können, kriegt auch nicht so jemand sein.
Ich stelle mir natürlich die Frage, warum ist denn sozusagen dieses Verzeichnis selber nicht auch nochmal verteilt und äh dementsprechend dezentral verfügbar.
Bis es. Ist es. Ist es, aber das ist eine. Viele ähm.
Also du kannst die Informationen an vielen Stellen bekommen, aber nur wenige Instanzen können diese signieren.
Das heißt also nur wenige können dafür bürgen, dass sie stimmt. Und wenn das äh nicht der Fall wäre, dann gäbe es einen relativ einfachen Angriff, dass du nämlich möglichst viele
bereitstellst, die irgendwie falsche Informationen geben und damit die Funktion von Thor signifikant beeinträchtigen.
Nur noch ein Türen bekommt, die keine sind.
Entweder das oder wenn du ein Angreifer von sehr starker Macht bist, zum Beispiel die Leute in ein Paralleltor schickst, wo du alle Notes,
ähm kontrollierst. Also ich könnte jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, ach du willst ins Tor, ja, dann nimm mal diesen hier,
Und da habe ich ihn manipulierten Entry, die der der dir irgendwie andere Keys gibt und dich irgendwie dreimal in meinem eigenen Datenzentrum äh hin und her schickt, dann kommst du am anderen Ende raus und ich kann's dann äh kontrollieren. Dann hättest du,
Könntest du die Leute in das Angriffsszenario führen, was vor ein paar Monaten,
so ein paar US-Forscher äh dargestellt hatten, wo sie gesagt haben, wenn ich alle drei Notes oder diese gesamte Torwolke kontrolliere, also Eingang Mitte und Ausgang, dann kann ich durch äh Trafficanalysen auch feststellen, wer wer war,
und das wäre kombiniert mit Fallschirm Directory Informationen geben, eben ein ein sinnvoller Angriff. Deswegen möchtest du nur wenige Instanzen haben, die
solche Informationen tatsächlich signieren können. Ursprünglich war das so, dass der Signing Key direkt auf der Afferity war
die auch spontan halt ihre Updates oder ihre Diffs und kleineren Teile signieren konnte. Ah da gab's irgendwann mal eine Änderung darin, wie die wie die Signing äh die genau funktionieren. Deswegen möchte ich mich da jetzt äh zu den genauen Details
ähm wie das technisch funktioniert, lieber zurückhalten.
Gut, gehen wir doch mal auf die nächste Meldung.
Ich würde gerne noch kurz was dazu sagen, denn es gibt eine interessante Frage, die du ganz zu Anfang gestellt hast und die lautete, wo kommt dieser Kram her?
Dieser Exkiescore. Denn es gibt eine große Debatte, denn ähm oder es gibt,
Aufgrund von zwei den zwei Leaks in den letzten sieben Tagen eine große Debatte und darin hat sich der äh geehrte Bruce Schneier zu Wort gemeldet und hat gesagt, er glaubt nicht, dass dieser Ex-Keyscore Quelltext liegt,
aus den Snowden-Dokumenten kommt. Er glaubt, dass es eine zweite Person,
gibt, die ähm liegt.
Snowden zwei,
interessant.
Also, der äh TAO, also Operationskatalog, der äh wo es was größtenteils das war, was Jacob Apple-Baum beim ähm,
C drei vorgestellt hat, wo es also um die die ganzen kleinen Hardwarespielereien geht, die die NSA offensichtlich auch bastelt.
Sozusagen.
Genau, diese,
Die ganzen James Bond Sachen und vor allem das schockierendere dadran ja nicht, dass sie's bauen, was was irgendwie klar ist, sondern dass sie auch eben diese Versandinfrastruktur von
Online-Händlern infiltrieren oder die gesamten die gesamten Paketpostwege infiltrieren, um ihre Geräte dann auch dahin zu bringen, wo sie die haben wollen, ne?
Ähm er sagt, dass er nicht davon ausgeht, dass das aus den Snowdendokumenten kam und dass er nicht davon ausgeht, dass diese Ex-Key-Score-Sachen von den neuen Dokumenten kamen. Und Bruce Schneier hat als eine der ersten Personen Einsicht,
in zumindest ein Teil des neuen Dokumente bekommen.
Und das ähm finde ich dann doch eine ganz interessante Hypothese, die ich an der Stelle dann noch kurz mit äh einbringen wollen. Tja.
Also ich meine das das würde dem Ganzen Ding auf einmal noch mal echt viel Dampf geben, wenn sich jetzt tatsächlich irgendjemand aus diesem Apparat denkt, scheiß drauf,
Wir drehen das Rad jetzt nochmal ein und äh hier gibt's einfach nochmal eine Quelle, die vielleicht auch ein bisschen anders arbeitet, so, die irgendwie aus dem Apparat heraus on demand.
Per Gmail und so.
Genau wird hier online. Äh die Daten per Mail an die Öffentlichkeit
schickt. Ja? Und sich unter Umständen auch gerade konkret viele Gedanken um Tor macht. Kann ja durchaus sein. Würde ja auch ganz gut jetzt passen zu der eigentlichen, geliebten Information an der Stelle, ne?
Ja ja also.
Jetzt äh super hypothetisch.
Aber den tatsächlich ich mein das Tor Traffic zu erkennen ist äh,
war doch klar und das wahrscheinlich auch, wer auch immer guckt zumindest darauf guckt, ist auch klar. Also ja.
Du stellst dir die Frage, warum das gelegt wurde.
Nee, ich ähm es ist ich bin eigentlich bei allen Nachrichten diese Woche,
Nee, überrascht, dass die so so einschlagen, weil das alles Sachen waren, von denen ich implizit ohnehin ausgegangen bin. Deswegen hätte ich nicht erwartet, dass die medial noch mal eine so große Aufmerksamkeit bekommen.
Und es wurde halt sehr groß äh abgefackelt dieses NSA zielt auf Tornutzer ab. Ich meine.
Das ist auch das immer immer wiederkehrende äh nützpolitische Aktivisten leiht, dass irgendwie Dinge, die man für total spektakulär hält, keinen interessieren,
hier irgendwie als völlig nebensächlich angesehen werden, auf einmal alle so in äh Schockstarre, äh Wallung und äh Schnappatmung bringen.
Ja, ja. Wahrscheinlich.
Aber muss ja auch vorsichtig sein, dass wir nicht an diesen Punkt kommen, äh da gab's ja in den Kommentaren, das fand ich übrigens auch interessante Kommentare, die sagten, dass meine Unaufgeregtheit über die Facebook-Studie
letzte Woche eben nicht zuträglich wäre, weil ich äh gefälligst Öl in das Feuer des öffentlichen
Zorns zu gießen habe, statt äh den Menschen aus der Sicht des informierten äh zu sagen, so regelt euch nicht auf. Äh das war schon immer so.
Wir ja hier ein aktivistischer Podcast sind und aktivistischer Podcast hat, einfach gefälligst Feuer zu entzünden.
Na ja, ich meine, man kann das schon, man kann das schon äh,
Also es, dieses ist halt schon auch zu kritisieren als als Perspektive, ne? Ich meine, wenn du wenn du dich zehn Jahre lang hinstellst und sagst, Facebook ist Mist, bleibt da weg, bleibt da weg,
weg und dann kommt endlich was, wo den Leuten gezeigt wird, warum sie da die ganze Zeit hätten wegbleiben sollen, dann zu sagen, habe ich doch gesagt, ähm,
im Zweifelsfall nicht dazu, dass die Welt eine bessere wird.
Fand ich ein, fand ich schon durchaus ein ein Argument.
So, ja, weiter äh geht's aber mit NSA. Da ist ja eine Menge zu holen und ähm ja, hier gab's eine eine Meldung der Washington Post. Und äh.
Ja, die hatten eine eine Datenbank von einhundertsechzigtausend abgegriffenen E-Mails und Chatmitschriften,
die irgendwie aus dem NSA,
Überwachung stammt, ähm in denen irgendwie insgesamt mehr als zehntausend Zielpersonen sich befanden.
Das ist jetzt auch wieder explizit äh Stuff.
Das ist auch hier wieder die interessante Frage, denn es wurde ja von der NSA immer wieder behauptet, ähm
snowden konnte nicht auf diese Daten zugreifen. Da redet irgendwie einer von Dingen, von denen er keine Ahnung hat. Der hat die ganze Zeit nur PowerPoints rausgetragen und weiß ja gar nicht, wie es wirklich ablief, weil ihm man ihn ja auch,
interessante Parallele. Diesen Vorwurf machen wollte, dass
der Snowden da einfach rausmarschieren kann. Es gab doch glaube ich auch mal irgendeinen CDU Politiker, der dann gesagt hat, äh ja, also den Amerikaner ist ja offensichtlich nicht zu traurig, wenn wenn denen da ihre äh Geheimdienstmitarbeiter einfach rausmarschieren.
Mit den Daten. Ähm ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wer das war. Ähm und da ist jetzt endlich nach, na, über einem Jahr Snowden-Enthüllung, jetzt tatsächlich mal,
sind jetzt wirklich zum ersten Mal wirkliche Überwachungsdaten. Ähm die geliebt wurden und die von der von der Presse untersucht wurden.
Und was äh stellen wir fest? Äh es sind alles überhaupt gar keine Terroristen, sondern um die neunzig Prozent der Leute, die dort äh mitgelesen werden, sind einfach,
Irgendwelche Leute. Genau. Normale Amigis und auch Nicht-Amis. Ja, was es da alles so Schönes drin.
Medizinische Formulare, die innerhalb einer Familie versendet wurden, Lebensläufe, Mitschriften von Schulkindern, alles, ja, irgendwie Daten zu Personen in Online-Chats, in dem sich Zielpersonen aufgehalten haben
Was sich dahinter verbirgt ist natürlich, wenn du irgendwie rum äh lauerst im Chat oder so, dann äh.
Mitschriften von Schulkindern. Vielleicht wollen die auch einfach nur so ein neues Hausaufgabenportal starten.
Ich glaube, die äh das mit diesen Schulkindern, das haben sie halt mit dazu geschrieben, um irgendwie war das so ungefähr das Harmloseste, ja, ja. Ähm.
Dabei wissen wir, Schulkinder ja also ne.
Und jetzt gibt's also auch hier jetzt aus meiner Sicht nicht viel Überraschendes, aber ähm man sieht eben,
Ich meine,
neunzig Prozent der NSA-Opfer keine Zielpersonen sind. Ich würde sogar schätzen, dass es neunundneunzig Prozent sind, weil es gibt einfach gar nicht so viele Zielpersonen. Es gibt einfach nicht so viele Menschen auf dieser Welt, die ernsthaft,
uns was böses wollen, gemessen daran, wie sich irgendwie der Westen irgendwie die ganze Zeit verhält, würde ich ja eigentlich erwarten, dass dass unsere, unser Kulturkreis sehr viel mehr Feinde äh auf dieser Welt hat. Ähm,
Und äh gemessen an den wenigen,
Erfolgen, die gefeiert werden in der Terrorismusabwehr, wie groß sie gefeiert werden und ähm wie lächerlich dann die Versuche äh sich am Ende dann doch als wie lächerlich sich diese Versuche am Ende entpuppen.
Offensicht, also entweder ist es ihnen egal oder die äh Zielgruppe, die man für potenziell kriminell oder zumindest überwachungswürdig hält, ist einfach nochmal viel größer als gedacht, ne.
Das ist ja eigentlich das Ding an der Stelle. Also gedacht, ist immer die Frage von wem gedacht oder sagen wir mal größer als gesagt? Ja, weil es wird ja dann immer,
Terroristen, die großen Umstürzler und jeder hat dann immer gleich wieder den nächsten Arnold Schwarzenegger Film äh im Kopf, wo irgendwelche äh Granatbehangen ähm,
super Schurken so aus den Bergen herabsteigen, um dann irgendwie als nächstes äh Fort Knox in den Duft zu jagen und
das ist halt irgendwie, glaube ich, nicht für dich so das Ding, worum's geht so. Und ich meine, es werden halt Finanzströme äh untersucht. Das wird im Prinzip nach allem geschaut, was,
irgendwie auf irgendwas eine Auswirkung haben kann und da zählt auch, glaube ich, dieses Gesetz in dem Sinne irgendwie überhaupt nicht mehr so richtig,
Also es geht nicht jetzt dadrum so äh wer ist hier kriminell oder wer ist hier super kriminell, sonst wird halt einfach erstmal alles mitgeschoben. Insofern ist diese Meldung jetzt auch nicht besonders beeindruckend, ne?
Na, was was noch? Also die Washington Post hat da ganz schöne Visualisierung. Was dann sehr interessant ist,
Ähm minimales. Also wo sie wie sie da Sachen gekürzt haben und aus welchen Ländern diese Sachen tatsächlich kamen. Ja und da ähm,
scheint sich schon sehr stark äh,
äh erkennbar zu sein, dass da viel, also wenn sie viele US IP-Adressen wegmachen, dann heißt das eben auch, dass sie viele US,
viel US Beifang in ihrem Schleppnetz dann da haben, ne?
Beifang im Datenschleppnetz. Schönes Bild.
Ja, aber auch da äh ich, wie gesagt, ich das war jetzt,
das war jetzt auch zu erwarten. Ich meine, das ist der gesamte das war der gesamte, das ist das gesamte Problem da dran. Niemand beschwert sich wirklich, wenn äh Straftäter äh oder Terroristen irgendwie überwacht werden, ne?
Es geht immer noch um die Überwachung der ganzen Menschen, der ganzen Unschuldigen. Und eben auch nicht so sehr um die gezielten Sachen
ja? Aber äh schön ist also, dass die äh was die generelle Praxis bei der NSA ist, während andere Behörden etwas, was sie als irrelevant ähm,
markieren, löschen, weil sie sagen, brauchen wir nicht.
Nur als irrelevant äh markiert.
Die NSA fleckt das nur für.
Ja. Ähnlich wie Facebook übrigens, ne? Facebook löscht ja auch nicht. Die schreiben auch nur dran, ist gelöscht.
Jedes Fallsystem macht das so.
Ja wobei.
Einfach der typische Nightway of so. Man löscht nicht. Man äh markiert als gelöscht. So ist das.
Jo
Und dann haben wir noch eine schöne ähm ein schönes Nahspiel zum Recht auf Vergessen.
Das sogenannte ja also Google markiert auch nur als gelöscht, ne? Sieht man jetzt auch sehr schön.
Google Google Pakete auswärts gelöscht und sagt dann, einige Ergebnisse wurden möglicherweise aufgrund der Bestimmung des Europäischen Datenschutzrechtes entfernt.
Ja, das ist jetzt schön. Das kriegt man jetzt am laufenden Meter vor die Nase geworfen, wenn man nach Dingen sucht.
Das ist so quasi so jetzt äh wie bei YouTube mit dem mit dem Gamer äh Hinweis, das nächste Ding mit ihr seid alle scheiße und riecht nach Lulu und ihr seid ja selber Schuld, dass ihr euch da so beschränken lässt und wir sind's ja nicht gewesen so, das ist.
Ich finde halt, dass das neue peinliche, also äh ich habe vor gestern war das ähm einen Namen gegoogelt und dann kam dieser Hinweis und da habe ich mir gedacht, aha,
Was hat er denn da gemacht? Was hat er denn? Warst du da verstecken? Was will er verstecken?
Ach, du meinst, dass man jetzt sozusagen,
Nein, nein, hier gibt's, hier gibt's, hier gibt's nichts zu sehen. Ist alles okay, ne, also das sind schon wirklich alle Suchergebnisse jetzt, die ich äh wirklich jetzt mal echt, ja, mehr äh habe ich nicht.
Ich find's ganz also man weiß natürlich nicht denn das, das was eigentlich interessanter, also Guardian und Spiegel,
haben jetzt darüber berichtet, wie es eben aussieht, wenn jemand so ein Recht auf Vergessensantrag bei Google stellt, denn sie haben ja dann ein Formular bereitgestellt und haben gesagt, hier kannst du nach neuer Datenschutz sagen, wir sollen was löschen
und da sind innerhalb kürzester Zeit einundvierzigtausend Anfragen eingegangen.
Allein aus Deutschland,
Ich glaube, es war ein sehr, sehr, sehr hoher Anteil aus Deutschland, aber ich hatte die Zahl noch ein bisschen größer in Erinnerung. Also, es kann nicht sein, dass das nur der Deutsche Anteil ist, den wir hier äh aufzählst.
Nee. Äh ach so.
Oder war das nur die Zahl der zulöschenden.
Siebzigtausend Anträge sind eingegangen, inzwischen neuere Zahl, zweihundertsiebenundsechzigtausend, einzelne Seiten sind betroffen, zwölftausend der Anträge kommen aus Deutschland.
Ah ja. Okay. Okay, dann gab das, was.
Das war jetzt so die, die, die, die frischere Zahl von von.
Na nur zweihundertsiebenundsechzigtausend Webseiten, na ja, ich meine, ist ja nix.
So und jetzt pass jetzt, wie funktioniert das? Also sage ich hin hier, ich möchte so und so. Und dann äh bei Spiegel Online wurde dann geschrieben, also mit einer Suche nach Scientology. Äh nee, tschuldigung, umgekehrt.
Spiegel Online hat über einen Namen berichtet im Zusammenhang mit Scientology,
Die Person, wenn sie denn dann jetzt äh ihr Name gegoogelt wurde, tauchte also dann irgendwie in den äh Google-Ergebnissen wahrscheinlich weit oben, weil es Spiegel Online ist mit Lala, Scientology, auf,
Und wenn man den Namen jetzt,
eingibt. Dann kommt dieser Hinweis, einige Ergebnisse wurden möglicherweise aufgrund der Bestimmung des europäischen Datenschutzrechtes entfernt. Wenn man aber nach seinen Tology ohne diesen Namen googelt,
dann findet man diesen Spiegelartikel noch. Ähm.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch ähm so in der Form sinnvoll,
denn die Argumentation des Urteils war ja, dass Google ein Profil über diese Person gebildet hat und aus diesem Profil über diese Person wird dieser Artikel entfernt,
Gleichzeitig wird der Artikel aber nicht vollständig von Google wegzensiert,
Weil wenn du etwas anderes wissen, wenn etwas anderes dein Interesse ist, dann wird dieser Artikel dir doch noch angezeigt. Aber wenn die spezifische Person dein Interesse ist, dann nicht.
Und was ich dann auch sehr spannend finde,
Betreiber von Webseiten, die sich bei Google angemeldet haben. Ich glaube, damit meinen sie die Google Webmaster Tools, wo du sagen kannst, hier mir gehört
diese Seite, geh mir mal bessere Statistiken dazu und so bekommen dann eine Mitteilung. Das heißt,
Kugel sagt dir, übrigens zu diesem Suchbegriff haben wir diese Seite jetzt,
Aus unseren Suchergebnissen gelöscht. Was ganz schön ist, weil dann natürlich ähm,
Diejenigen zum Beispiel einen Artikel darüber schreiben könnten, dass dieser Artikel gelöscht wurde und welcher das ist.
Welche Person sich das bezieht.
Und das macht halt der Guardian etwas schmerzbefreiter als der Spiegel, wo dann irgendwie eine Person Doogie, McDonald, ähm ein äh,
Schiedsrichter, der gelogen hat oder sowas. Ähm dann einfach nochmal verlinkt.
Wodurch es eine neue Meldung wird, die dann nicht mehr zum Vergessen gehört.
Muss die Person auf jeden Fall nochmal neu schreiben.
Die Frage ist wiederum, wenn das jetzt wieder aufgegriffen wird in einem neuen Artikel, darf wann darf dann dieser Artikel vergessen werden?
Wahrscheinlich, wenn die Person äh den Antrag stellt, ist ja ein neuer Artikel, muss ja ein neuen Antrag für stellen. Ich glaube, da weiß Google schon genau wie's wie wie man äh Bürokratie macht.
Na gut, aber das ist ja dann sozusagen äh eine neue Geschichte,
geht's ja nicht nur um die alte Geschichte, da geht's ja auch um die neue Geschichte und was ist dann wiederum jetzt der,
dass das Recht, dass man das machen darf, weil äh in dem Moment, wo man halt ja, es ist
Es bleibt es bleibt wirklich eine sehr schwierige Sache. Wo kommt eigentlich dieses Recht auf Vergessen äh Terminologie jetzt auf einmal her, die war ja, glaube ich, nicht Bestandteil,
Der des Urteils der EUH, des EUGH, oder?
Mich da nicht so dran erinnern, dass das da in dem Kontext so explizit gesagt wurde.
Glaube nicht, dass es.
So ein bisschen so der Medienbegriff dafür zu sein.
Ja, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das Recht auf vergessen werden, da zentrale in der Zentrale in der Argumentation dieses Urteils war. Das kann aber gut sein, das ist das wahr,
Ähm denn wie du dich sicherlich erinnerst, vorab ich die Sendung zu dem Thema gar nicht gemacht, sondern da hat der Andre erzählt.
Und Andre hat ja da auch eine interessante Position eingenommen, weil er eben da jetzt nicht äh mit der großen Aktivistenkeule draufgehauen hat,
Ja, also äh er sieht das Problem und er hat es ja auch, sagen wir mal sehr zivilspätig reflektiert und ähm das Urteil auch
Wer das nicht gehört hat, soll da auch nochmal reinhören. Tat das Urteil äh sagen wir auf mehreren Ebenen bewertet, unter anderem eben äh
Das ist ja überhaupt das erste Mal ist, dass auf der Ebene auch klar anerkannt wurde, dass eben für Google überhaupt erstmal europäische Gesetzgebungen gilt, dass also quasi der Ort der Dienstleistungen hier auch mal relevant ist und nicht der, wo irgendwie die Server stehen
Ähm was sicherlich zu begrüßen ist. Ähm.
Aspekt eben anzuerkennen, dass dort Profile über Nutzer erstellt werden. Das, was schon richtig ist, also ich bin da auch nach wie vor ähm,
zwiespältig diese Urteil äh gegenüber und was wir da jetzt ähm,
sehen, ist eben das, was zu erwarten war, ne, dass die Menschen eben genau das wegmachen, wo sie, wovon sie erkennen, dass es ihnen,
schadet. Jetzt weiß ich aber zum Beispiel diesen Hintergrund dieses äh Scientology Vogels kenne ich nicht. Vielleicht ist der da ja auch jetzt inzwischen ausgetreten.
Ja, aber das Problem ist, dass wir es hier wirklich meine zweihundertsiebenundsechzigtausend Webseiten,
die da betroffen sind, ja, die nicht komplett gesperrt sind, sondern Suche im Kontext von Personennamen äh gesperrt werden und das jetzt eben nur so zu Beginn. Also es ist halt eine riesige Welle und ich freue mich vor allem, welche
also das macht jetzt Google, ja, macht das gar nö, macht das irgendwie bing, keine Ahnung, was.
Ja doch, die haben also Bing hat auch angekündigt, dass sie da irgendwie in der Hinsicht was machen werden müssen. Ist ja, es ist ja, das Urteil ist ja jetzt da, das ist für ähm das ist ja nicht, ist ja kein reines Google-Urteil.
Ja gut, aber das heißt ja, das heißt aber ein einzelner muss sozusagen für jede nur irgendwie erdenkliche Suchmaschine des einzelnen irgendwie machen. So,
Viel Spaß mit Spaß mit.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ich bin mal gespannt, ob nicht eventuell das Ergebnis sein wird, dass man äh wenn man Datenschutz konsequent zu Ende denkt und sagt, okay was diese was Google macht, ist,
ein Informationsprofil über eine Person bilden, dann wär's unter Umständen konsequent zu sagen, okay ich habe Google nicht darum gebeten, ich habe keine AGBs von denen unterschrieben,
Also untersage ich denen das komplett. Und wenn man dann,
Google darf über mich kein Profil bilden, fertig. Also, das wäre jetzt.
Ja, aber die Frage ist, wie identifizierst du denn äh ich? Klar, wenn du irgendwie Tim Prit Love heißt, dann ist das vielleicht äh realisierbar und äh bei Linus Neumann geht vielleicht gerade noch was, aber äh Andreas Müller und Peter Schmidt haben's da, glaube ich, schon ein bisschen schwerer.
Ja, aber Tim, du kannst doch nicht jetzt immer mit mit der Praxis kommen und irgendwie dagegen eine schöne Theorie vorgehen.
Doch. Weil das ist ja sozusagen die also ich ich sehe da halt auch einfach da wird jetzt ein riesen Aufwand betrieben,
in einzelnen Unternehmen, die jetzt diesen Aufwand vielleicht auch technisch zu stemmen, tatsächlich in der Lage sind. Ich sehe das aber einfach irgendwann gegen die Wand fahren
einfach diese Unternehmen nicht mehr die ausreichende Kapazität, Kompetenz, äh Geldmenge, Sorgfaltspflicht et cetera, die können sich auch einfach vertun
Ja, also so ein äh zusätzlicher Filter, der nochmal über die eigentlichen Suchalgorithmen drüber, ich meine, wenn wenn eine Seite schlecht sucht, dann ist das irgendwie so ihr Problem so. Ja, aber wenn sie jetzt ihre gute Suche
schlecht ein, also nochmal einschränken muss so. Also ich sehe das einfach nicht, dass das dass das eigentliche Problem damit, langfristig greifbar,
bleiben wird. Das das ist eigentlich das, was ich sagen will. Du wirst jetzt mit den einzelnen Personen, die auffällige Namen zu komplizierten Themen haben, irgendwie Erfolg haben, aber das ist das Problem an sich löst, das sehe ich nicht so bin ich nicht so von überzeugt.
Die Frage ist, ob das überhaupt ein Problem ist. Also was ist überhaupt das, was ist denn hier das Problem? Darüber besteht ja jetzt erstmal gar nicht unbedingt Einigkeit. Also.
Für die einzelnen Personen meinst du jetzt oder für äh.
Das Problem nach diesem Urteil ist, dass äh Google eben und das ja da gibt's ja technisch auch gute Argumentationen für eben nicht eine ähm technisch gesehen nicht eine Suchmaschine ist,
sondern ein Index, der nach deren Kriterien irgendwie sortiert ist,
Und vielleicht gar nicht das widerspiegelt, was die Zielperson eigentlich ausmacht. Ähm,
Beispielsweise ähm könnte es ja sein, dass eine zu mir tatsächlich relevante Information.
Eben nicht nach den Kriterien, die Google an,
für Relevanz nach oben gespült wird. In Wirklichkeit aber sehr viel wichtiger ist. Das heißt, es ist ein Abiturer Algorithmus den Google da zur Anwendung bringt. Und gegen den werden sollen Menschen,
ermächtigt werden, sich,
zur Wehr zu setzen, weil überhaupt erstmal anerkannt wird, dass sie dass Google nicht sucht, sondern Profile bildet. Und das ist ja schon mal wie gesagt, ich habe da gar keine eigene Position wirklich zu, aber das äh ich versuche da der Argumentation zu folgen.
Geht mir genauso.
Ne? Und wenn die Argumentation, die ist, dass Google über mich ein Profil bildet und ich deswegen die Möglichkeit habe, Google zu sagen, das nimmst du aus meinem Profil raus,
wenngleich ich der Nachrichtenseite nicht verbieten kann, den Bericht zu löschen,
weil er eben stimmt.
Ja.
Ähm.
Ja wobei ich meine, wenn.
Frage ich mich aber, wie gesagt, logisch zu Ende gedacht, dann sollte ich doch eigentlich auch Google ganz verbieten können überhaupt ein Profil über mich zu bilden.
Ist auf jeden Fall eine interessante Fragestellung. Man könnte aber auch genauso nochmal das Fass aufmachen mit dem eigentlichen Bericht, wenn jetzt so quasi äh die Zeitung berichtet über äh diese Sache, ja? Und es wird allgemein von einem Gericht festgestellt
dass das jetzt nicht mehr so wichtig ist, in Bezug auf meine Person, ja? Könnte man ja auch genauso gut sagen,
Na dann muss halt dieser Artikel äh die Person nicht mehr erwähnen,
dann muss der Name anonymisiert oder gekürzt oder abgekürzt werden
oder rausgenommen werden oder der ganze Artikel muss verschwinden weil er sich eben auf eine Person bezieht, also weil einfach der Artikel selber in seiner Berichterstattung
genau das eigentliche Problem repräsentiert. Das ist ja also der Artikel ist ja das, woran sich die Leute äh stören.
Da leuchtet den Menschen aber ein, dass das dann das diese Löcher werden bei Nineteen eighty four, wo der Winston dann die die,
Geschichte reinwirft, die die um die Geschichte, die er umgeschrieben hat, ne. Also bei, bei Winston ist ja eigentlich damit beschäftigt, die Vergangenheit umzuschreiben, damit sie zur Gegenwart passt.
Und ähm das eine Tradition von wir archivieren das, was in Tageszeitungen stand,
für die Historiker kommender Generationen und so. Ähm die haben wir ja. Also überall Recht auf Vergessen,
argumentiert.
Sowohl argumentieren sowohl Datenschützer als auch dieses Urteil nicht gegenüber nicht in Bezug auf die Person, sondern,
In Bezug auf die Datenkrake Google, die hier der Gegner ist.
Keiner kommt auf die Idee, ähm den Zeitungen zu sagen, äh schreibt, löscht,
diesen Artikel vernichtet, die gedruckten Exemplare eurer Zeitung, die ihr verteilt habt. Äh reißt die Seite, äh schneidet den Artikel aus dem, aus dem Zeitungsarchiv aus und macht ihn nicht mehr verfügbar.
Die Argumentation ist, ist über diese Profilbildung. Und das ist echt, also ich meine, das ist wirklich äh ja, ich find's tatsächlich sehr interessant und mir fällt da auch keine Antwort zu ein. Aber es war,
klar, dass das die Folge sein würde, dass Menschen jetzt ihre äh Google-Ergebnisse prinzipiell zurecht ähm,
zensieren.
Ja, es ist so ein bisschen wieder wie mit diesem Google Streetfood, ja, also es es wird halt einfach so eine Pixelwand äh davor geschoben.
Ja, aber also denken, ich hatte es gab mal irgendwie so eine Menschensuchmaschine, Jasmin, glaube ich, hießen die.
Sagt, glaube ich, immer noch.
So eine richtige Internetpest. Das hat ein paar Jahre gedauert, bis Google ähm dann einfach die Wecke ähm äh weggedingst hat, aber die tauchten halt auch in den Suchergebnissen auf,
Und irgendwann hat Google dann dafür gesorgt, dass dieser haben den dann den Patchring runtergezogen und die aus ihren, die nach unten ausgefadet, ja
Wo man dann im Prinzip auch wieder sagen könnte, na ja, das was Google da getan hat, ist eine eine gezielte Manipulation ihres Algorithmus äh zur Benachteiligung eines Konkurrenten,
Den Namen googeln ist offensichtlich etwas, was viele Menschen tun,
Trotzdem finde ich es natürlich gut, dass es geschehen ist und ich fand Jasni halt die absolute Pest, aber es wird schwer technisch vom Vorgehen ähm,
Einen Unterschied zu definieren, warum Jasmin äh Mist ist und Google nicht, weil sie beide ähm,
etwas,
zu in diesem Fall jetzt deiner Person sammeln und aufbereiten. So Jasmin hat's jetzt nochmal irgendwie spezifischer und sagen, hier such doch mal hier den äh Tim Pritlaff. Wir äh bauen da Sachen zusammen und ähm,
Google sagt, du kannst da oben eingeben, was du willst.
Ne, aber prinzipiell die Argumentation ist, Google macht da eine, bildete ein Profil zu einer bestimmten Person.
Christian mal hier den Doggi. McDonald eingeben bei Jasmin.
Glaube ich nur deutsche Offner äh äh Opfer. Sicher? Weiß ich nicht.
Sicher. Ihr steht hier worldwide.
Dass das auch eine Piste, ja.
Ich bin froh, dass ich die irgendwie losgeworden bin. So, aber jetzt stell dir mal vor, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie ich das gemacht habe. Ich glaube, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Ich glaube, dass ich da irgendwie,
ähm den, die in der ausgeschlossen habe oder sowas, ist schon wieder ein paar Jahre her. Aber stell dir mal vor, du bist jetzt eine Person, die jetzt nicht,
Möglichkeit hat, durch bestimmte Patreons,
Einfach mal die zehn ersten Suchergebnisse zu kontrollieren.
Sondern du bist halt ein ganz normaler Mensch wie viele andere und es ist schon erstaunlich bei Menschen, die jetzt nicht eigene Webseiten unterhalten,
ähm oder sich sehr häufig in ähm in Medien äußern, wo es dann Medienberichterstattungen zu diesen Personen gibt, was für Suchergebnisse du zu denen findest und wie.
Völlig komisch das Bild ist, was sie halt auch teilweise zeichnen, ne. Also wenn jetzt gut, wenn ihr jetzt Angestellter bei einer Universität bist, dann kommt natürlich dann da deine Mitarbeiterseite als Erstes. Aber,
ähm ich habe jetzt vor ein paar Tagen auch echt mal nochmal Bekannte gegoogelt
und da kommen ganz verquere äh Dinge dann da oder irgendwelche uralten Bilder oder dass die irgendwann mal vor fünf Jahren beim Tennisturnier den sechsten Platz hatten und so. Das ist halt ziemlich peinlich, was was Google dann da abliefert. So, wir beide, wenn wir da draufgucken, da
äh da haben wir halt gut kacken. Aber ähm bei einigen ähm,
bei jetzt so dem Großteil der Menschen ist das durchaus ein ziemlich verzerrtes Bild, was so eine Suchmaschine da abliefert.
Oder eben ein nicht verzehrtes Bild und äh ein Scientology Mensch, der dann sich irgendwie der dann da eben Sachen wegzensiert. Also das, das, das ist ein spannendes, spannendes Ding.
Ja, wirklich schwierig deine Position zu finden. Ich glaube, das ist auch etwas, wo,
auch sagen wir mal an unserer Gemeinde der Diskurs so sich. Ähm mal bewähren könnte. Also ich fände das mal wirklich ein interessantes äh Problem da auch wirklich mal eine Position zu finden.
Also ich vielleicht läuft die Debatte schon und ich krieg's äh nur nicht mit so, ja, aber ähnlich wie auch bei diesem ganzen vermeide Daten Urheberrechts äh,
komplex, ja, gibt's ja nun auch wirklich sehr viel unvereinbare Grundannahmen und hier ist es halt ein ähnlicher Punkt.
Ja, du hast noch dann noch dazu kommt ja diese im Moment sehr schwallende äh und immer wieder auch von ähm in den Medien aufgegriffene ähm latente,
ja, Hass ist jetzt übertrieben, aber so dieses immer drauf eingewäsche auf, die amerikanischen Anbieter, ne? Das, was wir jetzt auch schon irgendwie seit seit Jahren hier so ein bisschen in unserer Berichterstattung immer wieder darstellen,
Das kann doch nicht sein, dass ein Google äh unsere Häuser äh äh fotografiert. Ähm gestern in der ARD dann einen Beitrag,
Cloud, die Cloud, die Cloud und so, ne, wo auch immer wichtige Punkte mit dabei sind. Aber im,
keiner müde wird von diesen Berichterstattern zu betonen, dass das ja bei den bei den Amis ist,
Ja und bei Google und dass man ja äh doch bitte zur T-Systems Cloud gehen soll, wo.
Alles anders ist.
Eben dann sowas auch mit kommerziellen Interessen verbunden ist,
Naja, okay, wir drehen uns im Kreis.
Das tun wir. Na ja, das.
Erstmal ein paar Google Ergebnisse von dir. Alles Gute,
Ich möchte, dass ihr, ich mache ein ich mache irgendwas Doofes, mal gucken.
Könnte ich das eigentlich irgendwie verhindern, dass jetzt andere Leute anfangen, unter meinem Namen? Äh da äh was zu beantragen
Ja, also man könnte ja im Prinzip auch so die ganze Netz äh die gewünschte Netz-Identität komplett vernichten. Äh wer überprüft das, ja? Wer überprüft, dass das auch wirklich äh
sich auf mich bezieht, ja, dieses Peter Müller äh Problem.
Ja, das werden sie irgendwie machen. Ich hab's mir vor allem noch nicht genau angeschaut.
Wie willst du das.
Ja werden sie, werden sie schon irgendwas machen? Lass mal gucken. Brauchst einen Benutzerzertifikat, Antrag auf Entfernung, aus der Suche Name,
Ihr eigener Name, Kontakt-E-Mail-Adresse, URLs, deren Entfernung sie beantragen, Begründung,
Unterschrift, wie auch immer deinen Namen hin oder so. Na, na, na. Wahrheitsgemäß hin.
Das Ganze dann bitte per Fakt.
Also da scheint jetzt erstmal keiner sinnvolle,
Signatur drin zu sein. Das wäre natürlich jetzt auch nochmal also es würde mich auch nicht wundern, wenn also Google hat ja so eine Tradition dadrin,
Wenn ihnen da irgendwie jemand mit Datenschutz kommt,
irgendwie maximal peinlich so umzusetzen, dass sich alle nur noch an den Kopf packen. Und zwar nicht wegen Google, sondern wegen der bescheuerten Legislation oder Urteile, was auch immer. Siehe, Streetfood-Debatte, ne, wo sie sagen,
Ihr wollt eure Häuser verpixeln? Sehr gut, dann
knallen wir da halt so die Maximalhässlichen äh tauschen, Weichzeichner drüber, irgendwie so schräg dran getackert und sagen unseren studentischen Hilfskräften nochmal extra, sie san halt möglichst so machen, dass das aus hundert Metern scheiße aussieht, dein Haus?
Und jeder sich denkt, was ein Depp,
So und dann sagen sie halt hier bitte schön tschüss. Und ähm ich könnte mir halt auch vorstellen, dass sie jetzt das gezielt,
so so unsicher und so ungeprüft wie möglich machen, dass halt irgendwie aller mögliche Mist aus allen möglichen Suchergebnissen gelöscht wird, bis irgendwann die Leute sagen, jetzt reicht's uns aber,
Ich weiß es aber nicht. Das wird Spekulation.
Ja. Berichte aus dem Land der Spekulation.
Aus dem Land der Spekulationen,
ähm habe ich hier noch drei Namen zu nennen, den ich sehr äh zu Dank verpflichtet bin. Das ist der Bernd Karcher, der Markus Müller und der Alex Gerhard.
Geht mal schön auf die Suche, was die ausgeheckt haben, ja.
Mal gucken, ob das, ob das dann Google noch zu finden ist, was die gemacht haben.
Ja, nee, wir haben natürlich jetzt hier vor Veröffentlichung der Sendung dafür gesorgt, dass sie komplett aus dem Netz verschwinden, damit man ihnen nichts nachweisen kann.
Als kleines Dankeschön habe ich da mal hier das Formular ausgefüllt.
Genau. Und wir so, wir werden äh noch ein paar Sendungen machen, bevor es irgendwann zu einer unweigerlichen Sommerpause kommen wird,
Und äh ich glaube schon, in den nächsten machen wir dann auch mal wieder was mit Gast und werden mal,
Ein bisschen noch ein bisschen mehr auf die Meter äh Ebene hier äh einsteigen.
Mit Sommerpause meinst du vor allem, dass jetzt also Parlament geht ja schon in die äh Sommerpause, ne?
Ja, nicht nur das Parlament. Also, ich meine, erstens wird so ein bisschen der, der Nachrichtenvorrat ausdünnen, also es wird sicherlich irgendwas immer irgendwie zu debattieren sein, aber äh unser eins wäre ja dann vielleicht auch nochmal die eine oder andere Reise antreten.
Das wird sich dann alles zeigen und ergeben, ansonsten bedanken wir uns hier erstmal für äh Neigung, Unterstützung, Zuhörbereitschaft äh et cetera. Äh genau. Und ähm,
Bis bald.
Bis bald, tschau, tschau.